we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i am gonna
play this voicemail for you and what i
want to tell you is that there are lots
of people who have been reacting to the
story I did about how to make money on
YouTube and this conversation I once had
with someone who said hey David would
you be willing to become a conservative
if it made you more money of course I
answered no a lot of people mistakenly
think that it was Dave Rubin who I had
lunch with who said that to me so I want
to play just one voicemail but this is
representative of a lot of confusion
around who it was that said that to me
okay let's take a listen David I just
heard I remember you said a long long
time ago I mean this was just a few
weeks ago that you had lunch for this
person and broadcast media and they told
you when you switch positions for a
higher salary well I just heard on The
Young Turks Ana Kasparian telling us
Dave Rubin muskie whitey Network because
he wanted to make $100,000 six-figure
salary was this person you have lunch
with dave rubin right it wasn't so yeah
I saw that segment on The Young Turks I
was actually surprised that Dave Rubin
didn't have a six-figure salary already
like that some of the dynamics of their
story at the Young Turks yeah some of
the dynamics of that story were
confusing to me but know what so when I
told that story I said it was a talk
radio industry person Dave Reubens not
in talk radio right he's an online media
so it was not Dave Rubin that I had
lunch with and to be clear when that
person asked me would I be willing to
become a conservative if it were to
double my salary
they weren't actually offering me a
position doing that what they were
trying to do I think is get me to think
about what is the goal of what I'm
building and is it just to make as much
money as possible or is there something
to the fact that it's a progressive show
and of course breaking news there is
something to the fact that it's a
progressive show I wasn't indifferent
between doing a conservative show or a
progressive show I was only going to do
a show that actually reflected my
genuinely and sincerely held political
beliefs so it was not Dave Rubin and it
was not even anyone from
online media well and I just punched my
mic because it's so so agitating for me
it was somebody from from yak radio
industry that most people have probably
never heard I was just gonna say I think
the audience members will still try to
guess so it's not Dave Roux but maybe
it's this person or this person you're
not gonna come up with the right guy
it's an exam enough it's an executive
person and it is not someone that is
well-known outside of the industry
because they're really an industry
person but it doesn't matter who it is
whether it's Dave Rubin or whoever else
I'm not becoming a conservative okay
don't worry about it we've got a great
bonus show coming up for you today
access the bonus show by becoming a
member at WWJ in pac-man comm or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will talk to you
either on the bonus show or tomorrow